there's no way in the world these people
were gonna be able to charge me with
shootings based on what I rap about you
may have heard of hip-hop rapper Tinie
tuba for tiny dude both up fake
following with rap music dissecting gang
life including his new album no safety
his real name is Brandon Duncan and he
got a lot of attention after spending
about eight months in jail awaiting
trial for conspiring to commit a series
of gang-related shootings around San
Diego California prosecutors said he
didn't have anything to do with the
actual crime he didn't shoot the gun or
drive the getaway car instead they said
he benefited from the crimes through his
violent gangster rap news the complaint
based on a little-known statute making
it illegal to gain from gang activities
alleges he did willfully promote further
assist and benefit from criminal conduct
by members of that gang
how can you promote crimes you don't
even know about I was the first thing I
was thinking about and I was like this
is crazy like there's no way in the
world these people were gonna be able to
charge me with shootings based on what I
rap about in my music but just dismissed
the charges against Duncan in March 2015
but you may be surprised to know that
his story is just one of many criminal
cases or small-time rap artists wind up
having their music used against them
over the last decade gang prosecutors
across the United States have combed the
internet for rap music and rap videos
and social media posts putting together
cases against would be rappers full of
scary rap lyrics and very little
physical evidence of a crime being
committed and in this case it was no
safety your rap album but also a few
Facebook photos right facebook photos
from parties not me hanging on a street
corner or something like that but if I
was who cares like I'm not wrong for
that that doesn't say I'm committing a
murder because you see me in a picture
with a couple of people from my
community like saying hey he's a
murderer because of this or he committed
shootings because he was standing in on
a street corner with some people like
that's all right
Duncan says it's guilt by association
everything I say every color are weird
like right now this t-shirt me sitting
here would you based off of the the
district attorney's a analogy you can be
labeled a gang member or be documented
as a gang member because of the shirt
you got on because of the shoe color you
have on because of the shirt and you and
you're with me we're doing a we're
taping right now we're filming right now
so you're in this film with me and you
know I'm a documented gang member in
their eyes so you know it was associated
you're associated with me so everything
you say from here on out you can be
charged for it's not okay
what gang would I be a part of with the
crib you're a crap yeah you're a career
yeah your crib with these dumb glasses
down you're a [ __ ] man doesn't matter I
had on glasses in my pictures Duncan
grew up in Lincoln Park a suburb of San
Diego and while there is gang activity
there he says he's moved on from that
part of his life was wrap your way out
of this sort of thing he said you're not
a part of the gang anymore yeah no I'm
not a part of a gang I'm rap is my way
out and no and that's that's the whole
thing about rap is you know me you
create this platform to where you can
help a whole lot of people you know that
normally wouldn't have helped that
normally would be stuck right there and
that ghetto you know I'm gonna be stuck
in ice a knighthood you know but instead
we try to you know give jobs out calling
these tours and you know just create
different you know I mean situations to
where you can get out of there for a
minute and you can go to these LA's and
you
I mean Florida's and you know you get to
go to these different places in New York
I mean I've been every without am in a
lot of places just based off a rat can
you talk a little bit about rap battles
for people that don't understand like
what a rap battle might be it's sort of
a a way to bring violence off the street
exist and make it non violent exactly so
it's like okay so you got two people say
you guys got animosity a little bit
animosity both rappers instead of
getting in instead of giving like you
know into these gun battles on the
streets he goes in the studio he says
what he says you're going to sudo you
say what you say but you guys keep it on
wax you don't take it into the streets
it's like who had a doper verse you know
I mean who had to dope her song you know
I mean that's who wins do bable a
metaphor a rudder for ya rhyme who has
the big it like I said the better
rhymes you know I mean that's the way
you know you take violence out of the
street but I mean your name is Brandon
Duncan but your rap name is tiny dude
where does the tiny do come from well
that's the name I got from my back in
the day my uncle called him you know so
I just ran with him it's a nickname
yes something name is it a character you
play I mean is that when you rap are you
tiny do is different from Brandon Duncan
but of course you know Brandon Duncan is
you know the father that's Pat doing my
thing with my kids and Brandon Duncan I
mean excuse me tiny do is in the studio
working and trying to put the food on
the table you're gonna get to the next
situation the next flight so say Al
Pacino movie Scarface he was Tony
Montana when he goes home he's Al Pacino
you know the name so when he goes home I
don't think he's snorting cocaine and
shooting people it's just that's who he
played on that movie and now was it
harmless or negative it was terminator
and the movie terminated but when he got
home he's Arnold Schwarzenegger you know
the father the grandfather if he is you
know mean the governor the governor yes
you mean that's who he is but you know
it's it's it's it's it's entertaining
and that's what people need to
understand it's not real life it's just
entertainment
I think it's just like a movie like the
more shooting you have in the movie the
more it you know I mean people were
compelled to like you know I mean to
really really really want to tune in so
I think that's what it's more about the
more uh you know shooting you talk about
in your raps them were people that like
you know a certain type of stuff like
that is gonna want to go grab that album
like oh man I was dope he was talking
about some crazy stuff on me I want to
go get that you know I mean so it's just
like there's just any time Johnny Cash
like one sort of song saying that he was
gonna shoot a man in Reno just to watch
him die
right Bob Marley said that he would
shoot the sheriff but he wouldn't shoot
the deputy
how can people still think that rap is a
real thing rather than just a metaphor
like these other songs I just I just
think because you can scare juries with
rap you're not gonna scare jury with
Johnny Cash because probably half the
jury listens to Johnny Cash they don't
listen to rap music so therefore they're
like well I understand what Johnny I
know Johnny Cash didn't shoot anybody
but because he doesn't know that because
half the jurors don't know the little
black boy out there they like well he
may have shot somebody he's black he
lives in the cattle he's a gang member
so he may have done what he's talking
about in those rats what kind of advice
would you give to law enforcement
prosecutors police officers when they
look at rap on line I really don't think
you could unless somebody's talking
about a crime that you know they
committed it doesn't make any sense to
even look at rap like why would you why
would you look at look for rap look for
evidence real evidence not you know
music this is not right are you still
going to be writing gangsta rap yes are
you say that all scared of no I'm not
well you owe me back in jail I'm not
scared of you anymore I want to be there
but I'm not scared of it
especially if you're gonna try to tell
me I can't make the music I want to make
like now it's not right
his art no it's like Basquiat he's a
painter and he was well at it if I'm a
rapper and I'm well at it that's what
I'm gonna do
I rap and I'm we're like I can do it you
know and so that's what I like to do
Studios more candies that's where I
paint my picture